[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend das sportliche das gibt
später mit Norbert König Abend und die
nahosteskalation die bleibt Nachrichten
bestimmendes
[Musik]
Thema hunderte Luftschläge Israel
bereitet seine Bodenoffensive auf Gaza
vor und wnet sich dafür mit
Einheitsregierung und
kriegskabinett Arbeitspflicht für
Asylbewerber unter anderem das fordern
die Bundesländer um die Herausforderung
der Migration besser stemmen zu
können und mindestens 500 € mehr pro
Monat ein Lohnplus von 10,5% verlangen
die Gewerkschaften für die Beschäftigten
der
Länder Tag 5 seit dem Terrorangriff der
Hamas mit mindestens 1200 Toten und 150
Entführungen ein Tag an dem israelische
Regierung und Opposition ein gemeinsames
kriegskabinett beschlossen haben
möglicherweise auch Indi für eine kurz
bevorstehende Bodenoffensive und während
sich die Situation im Gazastreifen nach
israelischen Bombardierungen verschärft
gibt es auch in Israel immer wieder
Bombenalarm wie in diesen Minuten im
Norden mehr von L
walpot sicherheitsalarm am Abend im
gesamten Norden Israels aus dem Libanon
drangen mehrere bewaffnete drohen auf
israelisches Gebiet vor von der
schiitischen Terrororganisation
Hisbollah gab es bislang keine
Bestätigung für die Angriffe eine
weitere Verschärfung der Lage so scheint
es bereits am Morgen hatte das
Sicherheitskabinett undter
Regierungschef Netanyahu weitere
Schritte beraten am Abend dann trat die
Opposition einer Notstandsregierung bei
ein kriegskabinett soll Israel jetzt
führen rund um den Gazastreifen im Süden
des Landes setzt die Armee ihren
Aufmarsch fort tausende Soldaten
Reservisten schwere Ausrüstung und auch
die Bombenangriffe auf hamasziele in
gazaastifen dauern an die Zahl der Toten
dort steigt die Versorgungslage ist
dramatisch die Krankenhäuser sind
überfüllt nicht nur mit Verletzten auch
mit
Schutzsuchenden unser Haus war gleich
neben der Universität und dem
Finanzministerium es wurde um 1 heute
Nacht getroffen aber wir hatten Glück
der Rote Halbmond hat uns in einem
Konvoi hier ins Hospital
gebracht als Anlaufpunkte für die
Menschen werden auch Schulen genutzt
aber auch sie sind inzwischen überfüllt
unhilfsorganisationen versorgen die
Menschen die Vorräte gehen zur Neige
unterdessen begräbt Israel seine Toten
nach neuesten Zahlen
100 viele Leichen müssen noch
identifiziert
werden wir helfen hier ein Grab
auszuheben für einen unserer
Soldaten ein Land vereint in Schock und
Trauer Michael bwerunge ist für uns in
der Nähe des gazerastreifens Michael
israelische Regierung und Opposition tun
sich zusammen bilden ein gemeinsames
kriegskabinett was liest du daraus
ab na ja das ist ein erster Erfolg
politische Einigung zu Zielen es wird
eine Art kriegskabinett geben ein trium
virat aus Benjamin Netanyahu dem
Verteidigungsminister Galland und dann
neu einem der starken Männer Benny Gars
exverteidigungsminister und Führer der
Partei nationaler Einheit das ist ein
Signal nach draußen allerdings fehlt der
Oppositionsführer der Führer der
stärksten stärksten Partei jair lapit
der hat gesagt ich gehe nur in diese
Regierung rein wenn die extremistischen
siedlerparteien rausgehen Michael vielen
Dank bis hierher du stehst aktuell in
Beeri in der Nähe da haben sich
schlimmste Massaker ereignet das
israelische Militär hat dir diese Orte
heute gezeigt wir wollen gleich weiter
darüber sprechen verschaffen uns aber
zunächst einen Überblick nur wenige
Kilometer vom Gazastreifen entfernt
liegen die kibutze Beeri und Reim dort
fand der terrorüberfall der hammersstadt
und Axel Konrad fasst jetzt einige
Bilder dieser unvorstellbaren
Geschehnisse für uns
zusammen als die israelische Armee am
Sonntag den kibut Beeri befreite fand
sie einen weiteren Ort des Grauens vor
17 Stunden lang hatten die hamaskämpfer
hier gewütet am Nachmittag konnten auch
Journalisten an den Ort und mit den
Soldaten sprechen die drei Tage mit den
Terroristen gekämpft
hatten wir dachten schon wir hätten den
Ort befreit doch immer wieder kamen
Gruppen von Terroristen aus ihren
stecken und griffen uns an es war ein
sehr verlustreicher
Kampf die Überwachungskamera am
Eingangstor zeichnete den Beginn des
Angriffs auf die ersten Kämpfer kamen um
kurz vor uh das erste Opfer gab es nur
Sekunden
später die Terroristen gingen von Haus
zu Haus erschossen die Bewohner oder
verschleppten Sie was der Kommandeur
hier vorfand kann er kaum in Worte
fassen
ich bin fast 40 Jahre Soldat habe in
allen Kriegen gekämpft so etwas habe ich
noch nie gesehen das kann man sich
einfach nicht
vorstellen Menschen Kinder wurden erst
gefesselt und dann enthauptet das hier
so der Offizier sei kein Krieg kein
Schlachtfeld es sei ein
Massaker noch mal zu Michael beunge in
unmittelbarer Nähe der Ort an dem diese
unfassbaren Dinge die wir gerade gesehen
haben geschehen sind Michael bitte teile
deine Eindrücke mit uns was hast du dort
heute
erfahren ja ich stehe hier in berie man
sieht viele Panzer im Hintergrund die
Armee hat uns Journalisten heute
mitgenommen hier zu diesem Ort und es
ist unglaublich was hier sich ereignet
hat was wir von Soldaten erzählt
bekommen haben beri ist eine
Geisterstadt manche Häuser sind zerstört
von den Kämpfen es liegt noch immer
Leichengeruch in der Luft und ich habe
mit einem Soldaten gesprochen er hat
mich zur Seite genommen er sagte ich war
als einer der ersten Kämpfer hier ich
habe selber Kinder gesehen die
enthauptet worden sind Kinder denen mit
Kabelbindern die Hände zusammengebunden
worden waren die in ihren Schutzräumen
erschossen worden sind also selbst die
hartgesotten Soldaten hier die viele
Schlachten geschlagen haben sagen so
etwas haben sie noch nie erlebt der der
Soldat sagte bitte erzähl das der Welt
viele Vergleiche würden gemacht und
viele würden nicht zutreffen aber ihn
würde das schon an einen Pogrom des
Holocaust erinnern jetzt hier war hat es
gesehen hinter mir ist beri ein einziges
großes Militärlager wir haben hier
hunderte Soldaten und Panzer gesehen
hier ist davon auszugehen 4 km von der
Front entfernt dass diese Soldaten als
erste Welle in die Bodenoffensive gehen
werden live aus beri in Israel in der
Nähe des gaz schifens Michael bwerunge
vielen Dank ja tausende Deutsche haben
Israel bereits auf eigene Faust
verlassen viele aber sitzen noch fest
für morgen und übermorgen hat das
Auswärtige Amt jeweils vier Sonderflüge
der lufthanser angekündigt auf der Liste
der Botschaft stehen rund 5000
Ausreisewillige andere Länder wie
Spanien oder Italien haben schon
Staatsbürger ausgeflogen auch mit
Militärmaschinen der islamistische
Terrorangriff prägt te heute auch das
deutsche Parlament im Bundestag wurde
mit einer Schweigeminute der vielen
Opfer in Israel gedacht und das was man
zuletzt immer wieder häufig hörte stand
auch heute im Mittelpunkt nämlich dass
die Sicherheit Israels zur deutschen
staatsreson gehöre Ines Trams
berichtet stehende Ovationen für den
israelischen Botschafter in Deutschland
gemeinsam mit dem Bundespräsidenten im
Bundestag als klares Zeichen Deutschland
steht hinter Israel die
Bundestagspräsidentin spricht von
beispiellosem Terror der durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen sei wir akzeptieren auch
nicht wenn grausamste Verbrechen gegen
Kinder Frauen und Männer bei uns in
Deutschland auf den Straßen oder im Netz
gefeiert werden wenn Terror verherrlicht
wird schweigemine für die Opfer des
Angriffs der Hammers auf
Israel bei der Befragung der Regierung
verteidigt sich Außenminister berb gegen
Kritik das Auswärtige Amt hätte deutsche
Staatsbürger zügig unterstützt 17
Schulklassen seien bereits ausgereist
über Jordanien oder Island es sind auch
etliche tausend in den letzten Tagen
über diese Umwege dann rausgeflogen
währenddessen haben wir alles dafür
getan dass deutsche Airlines wieder
fliegen und ich bin dankbar dass das
dann ab morgen auch der Fall ist dass
alle dann wieder auch direkt nach
Deutschland fliegen können die
humanitäre Hilfe für die Palästinenser
sollte nicht eingestellt
nochmals würde nun überprüft dass die
Gelder nicht von der Hamers missbraucht
würden es wäre falsch die
lebensnotwendige humanitäre Hilfe die
Versorgung von Familien mit Wasser Essen
und Lebensmitteln jetzt einzustellen
denn auch das ist Teil des Kalkül des
Terrorismus im Bundestag ist man sich
heute einig parteiübergreifend wird
erklärt die Sicherheit Israels gehöre
zur deutschen
staatsron ja zur dramatischen Lage in
narost und zur Frage was das israelische
Militär plant gibt's um 19:30 Uhr ein
ZDF heute live auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen und in der ZDF heute App und
dann auch mit unserem Korrespondenten
Michael
bwerungen durch die Eskalation in Nahost
fürchtet die Ukraine dass Ihnen
möglicherweise mittelfristig die
Unterstützung fehlen könnte um ein
deutliches Zeichen zu setzen reiste der
ukrainische Präsident deswegen
überraschend nach Brüssel wie er dort
empfangen wurde und welche Botschaften
wo lodomir selenski setzte dazu Ulf
Röller es kommt nicht oft vor dass NATO
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg vor dem
Eingang wartet Ankunft des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski der ist hier um
sicherzustellen dass die natopartner ihm
weiter helfen gerade jetzt wo auch
Israel Hilfe braucht für selenski muss
beides
gehen es war für uns sehr wichtig nicht
allein zu sein das hilft deinem Land zu
überleben und es rettet
Menschenleben mein Ratschlag an alle
Regierungschefs geht nach Israel und
unterstützen sie die Menschen die die
Terroristen
angreifen es geht bei diesem Treffen
darum die Hilfen für die Ukraine weiter
abzusichern denn in den USA gibt es
einen innenpolitischen Streit darüber
vorerst sieht der Haushalt keine
ukrainehilfen vor Stoltenberg
Solidaritätsbekundung soll
beruhigen ihr Kampf ist unser Kampf ihre
Sicherheit ist unsere Sicherheit ihre
Werte sind unsere Werte Deutschland
liefert unter anderem weitere
Flugabwehrraketen vom Typ Iris t und
Gepard Panzer das gesamte
verteidigungspaket Habe einen Wert von
rund einer Milliarde Euro und die USA
stellen der Ukraine weitere Militärhilfe
zur Verfügung Wert rund 190 Millionen
EUR darum die Ukraine in dem zu
unterstützen wobei sie den größten
Bedarf hat und das ist gerade zum
winterhin die Luftverteidigung der
Schutz des ukrainischen Himmels der
Schütz der kritischen Infrastruktur der
Energieversorgung selenski hat viel
Rückendeckung und Zusagen für Waffen
bekommen denn der Ukraine steht ein
schwieriger Winter
bevor bei den Landtagswahlen in Bayern
und Hessen haben die ampelparteien eine
Klatsche einstecken müssen und die
Asylpolitik spielte da ein wichtige
Rolle jetzt hat sich die Bundesregierung
auf Maßnahmen verständigt Migration zu
begrenzen geplant sind Verschärfungen
und Erleichterungen einerseits sollen
geflüchtete leichter in Jobs kommen
andererseits sollen Abschiebungen
erleichtert und beschleunigt werden
Klaus brotbeck dazu so wichtig ist diese
Einigung der Ampel dass der Kanzler
kurzfristig selbst darüber berichten
will eine große Entscheidung stand noch
aus an der viel gearbeitet worden ist
nämlich ein rückführungspaket mit denen
wir dazu beitragen dass die Rückführung
von denjenigen die nicht in Deutschland
bleiben können effizienter schneller
zügiger und auch einfacher gelingen kann
der ausreisegewahrsam soll von 10 auf 28
Tage verlängert die Ausweisung von
Schleusern und auch organisierten
Kriminellen erleichtert und
Abschiebungen auch bei Nacht und in der
Regel ohne die bisher nötige einmonatige
Vorankündigung möglich werden Reaktionen
vieles klingt auf den ersten Blick
ausgesprochen vernünft
und nimmt vor allen Dingen auch Hinweise
auf der aus der Praxis auf also
insbesondere von den Ausländerbehörden
und von der Polizei und das ist gut das
hätte längst umgesetzt sein müssen wir
brauchen das Ausweiten der sicheren
Herkunftsländer die magrebstaaten also
Marokko Tunesien Algerien aber auch
Armenien und Indien müssen zu sicheren
Herkunftsländern erklärt werden und wir
brauchen vor allen Dingen ein Stopp der
illegalen Migrationen wer eine
Bleibeperspektive hat s leichter in
Arbeit kommen der Stichtag dafür wo die
gut vi Jahre nach hinten geschoben für
eine beschäftigungsduldung soll nur noch
mindestens 20 Wochenstunden und 12 statt
bisher 18 Monate Vorbeschäftigung
erforderlich sein Berufsschüler sollen
ausbildungsduldungen erhalten das ist
ein Riesenschritt für die Kommunen für
die geflüchteten Menschen und vor allen
Dingen für Wirtschaft und Handwerk die
AFD kritisiert die Ampel alles zu spät
sie übernimmt jetzt oder gibt vor
einzelne Forderungen von uns zu
übernehmen wie Abschiebung oder
Sachleistung was wir seit Jahren fordern
was sie seit Jahren blockiert haben und
mit den Grünen werden sie das auch nicht
umgesetzt kriegen noch muss das Gesetz
durch den Bundestag ein wichtiger
Schritt aber scheint heute
getan Afghanistan ist erneut von einem
Erdbeben erschüttert worden und wieder
hat es die Region herad im Westen des
Landes getroffen laut US-Angaben hatte
das Beben eine Stärke von
6,3 lokale Behörden und
Hilfsorganisationen berichten von großen
Schäden und etwa 120 verletzten erst am
Wochenende waren in der Region bei
mehreren schweren Erdbeben laut
Medienberichten fast 2500 Menschen ums
Leben
gekommen in die USA die Republikaner
haben Steve sces für das Amt des
Sprechers im Repräsentantenhaus
nominiert er gilt als erztkonservativ
und war bisher se der Stellvertreter
Kevin McCarthy ist abgesetzt worden auf
Betreiben der Republikaner der Vorwurf
war er habe im Haushalt it gemeinsame
Sache mit den Demokraten
gemacht die Bundesregierung geht davon
aus dass die deutsche Wirtschaft in
diesem Jahr schrumpft in ihrer
Herbstprojektion rechnet sie mit einem
Rückgang der Wirtschaftsleistung um
0,4% im Frühjahr war man noch von 0,4%
plus ausgegangen die Ursachen sieht
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck unter
anderem in der Inflation und den
steigenden Zinsen 2024 soll es mit 1,3%
dann wieder Berg aufgehen
für rund 1,2 Millionen Beschäftigte der
Länder fordern die Gewerkschaften eine
zweistellige Lohnerhöhung mindestens
aber 500 € monatlich mehrteilten wer die
und der deutsche Beamtenbund mit in der
letzten Tarifrunde hatten sie sich
coronaabedingt mit 2,8% zufrieden geben
müssen die Verhandlungen starten Ende
des Monats Hans Jürgen Piel
berichtet sie sorgen für Sicherheit auf
Landesstraßen Ralf wobel ist werdi
Vertrauensmann beim Landes
riebstraßenbauen Verkehr in
Schleswig-Holstein ihm und seinen
Kollegen geht es diesmal vor allem um
einen spürbaren Inflationsausgleich wir
merken es beim Tanken wir merken es bei
der Versicherung wenn Sie hier auf der
Straßenmeisterei tätig sind sie müssen
ja immer zu dem Arbeitsplatz kommen sie
müssen zusätzliche Spritkosten bezahlen
da merken sie schon deutlich die
Tarifforderung passt zu den Erwartungen
10,5% mehr Gehalt mindestens aber 500 €
fordern werdi und Beamtenbund für den
öffentlichen Dienst der Länder das ganze
bei 12 Monaten Laufzeit es ist richtig
zu spüren da ist Druck auf dem auf dem
Kessel und
dann W sehen wir mal wie der
Verhandlungsverlauf ist wir sind auf
alles vorbereitet erst im April hatte
die Gewerkschaft bei Bund und Kommunen
Gehaltserhöhungen von mindestens 340 €
durchgesetzt jetzt sollen knapp 1,2
Millionen Landesbedienstete
vergleichbares
erhalten das ist too much das bekommen
wir so nicht hin und wir müssen ja auch
sehen D gerade die Länder die auch
finanziell wirklich nicht so gut
aufgestellt sind nachher die Sorge haben
dass sie Stellen streichen müssen oder
Streichung an anderer Seite vornehmen
müssen um das zu finanzieren mit
unzähligigen Warnstreiks und einem
bundesweiten Ausstand im Verkehrssektor
hatte werdi im Frühjahr das öffentliche
Leben bereits lahm gelegt und auch jetzt
ist man zu Arbeitskämpfen
bereit jetzt sind wir beim Sport wir
sind bei Norbert der neue
fußballbundestrainer hatte heute seine
erste aktive Amtshandlung ganz genau vor
den Spielen gegen gegen die USA und
Mexiko jetzt kann es richtig losgehen
Ärmel aufkrempeln heißt es
neubundestrainer julian nagelsmann hat
seine Auswahl zu den ersten
Trainingseinheiten versammelt nach der
Ankunft von Nachzügler kai hawerz ist
der 26er Kader jetzt
komplett der neue Chefcoach und
Sportdirektor Föller legen los beim
ersten Training ist Julian nagelsmann
voller Energie Detail besessen und er
überzeugt mit modernen Trainingsinhalten
mit dem flicknachfolger ist wieder Zug
drin nagelsmann kommt teamintern sehr
gut an und ist sehr präsent bei den
Ansprachen das was er uns mitgegen hat
war kurz war knapp war aber auch konkret
und klar und ich glaube das ist wichtig
dass diese Mannschaft auch klare Ansagen
bekommt die deutschen Gäste und günduan
der auch unter nagelsmann Kapitän bleibt
bekamen dann noch von examerican
footballpi Markus kunuh Trikots der New
England Patriots geschenkt aber gegen
die USA werden sie dann wohl doch in DFB
Shirts
spielen Deutschlands beste
handballspielerinnen tragen morgen in
Wetzler wieder Nationaltrikots zum
Auftag der
europameisterschaftsqualifikation gegen
das Team der Ukraine die für Samstag
geplante zweite Partie in Israel wurde
aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen auf
unbestimmte Zeit
verschoben eine ungewöhnliche Situation
für das DHB Team der sportliche Aspekt
der Start in die EM Qualifikation rückt
fast in den Hintergrund Vorstellung dass
Krieg so nah bei uns ist dass es jetzt
auch noch ja irgendwie in eine Woche
zusammenfällt diese Qualispiele gegen
Mannschaften im Kriegszustand ist schon
ja eine Ironie des Schicksals das Spiel
in Tel Aviv kann nicht stattfinden aber
morgen geht es in Wetzler gegen die
Ukraine ganz schwer irgendwie auch damit
umzugehen natürlich wollen wir versuchen
uns auf den Handball zu fokussieren und
es ist super wichtig für uns die EM
Quali erfolgreich zu absolvieren
Deutschland will seiner Favoritenrolle
gerecht werden zul gab es se Siege
nacheinander diese Serie soll möglichst
ausgebaut
werden und viertes Team in der deutschen
Gruppe ist die Slowakei Norbert vielen
Dank sie erfahren jetzt wie die Zahlen
vom Mittwochslotto lauten 3 16 25 30 31
42 Superzahl 3 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden Sie dann auf lotto.zf.de und auf
der ZF Textseite
so morgen im Süden noch schön sonst kühl
und regnerisch mehr gleich von Katja
horneffer um 21:45 Uhr das heute journal
mit Christian sieas das war's von uns
schönen Abend schönen Dank und gerne bis
[Musik]
morgen guten ab Abend heute kam Programm
gemäß die Kaltfront hier von Nordwesten
heran ab den Mittagsstunden begann es in
Schleswig-Holstein zu regnen und diese
Kaltfront sieht jetzt am Abend und in
der Nacht weiter südwärts bis morgen
früh wird sie die Mittelgebirge erreicht
haben und dann passiert mit dieser
Kaltfront nur noch wenig von Westen
kommt neuer Regen hinterher und dann
verabschieden sich die Regenwolken
ostwärts heute Nacht ist es also in
Süddeutschland noch mal klar Lokal kann
sich Nebel bilden und in der kaltfon
kann sich in N Deutschland auch mal ein
Gewitter entwickeln unter den dichteren
Wolken bleibt es mild bei 11 bis 16°
Kühler wird's an der Ostsee und auch in
Bayern mit 10 oder 9° und morgen wird
für die meisten von uns eher ein
bedeckter Tag mit Regen in
Süddeutschland bleibt's noch freundlich
und hinter der Kaltfront lockern die
Wolken im Nordosten auf dort liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen nur so bei 14 15° im
Süden werden dagegen 22 bis 27° erreicht
noch wärmer wird's dann am Freitag bis
zu 29° der Samstag wird dann schon sehr
stürmisch wechselhaft und gewittrig und
der Sonntag kalt guten Abend